un son auquel la plupart des riverains
l'aéroport lyonnais de saint-exupéry
s'étaient habitués mais dans cette zone
la fin du confinement marque le début
des ennuis nocturne pour des milliers de
résidents avec la reprise des vols de
nuit l'aéroport reprend progressivement
ce lundi son activité en temps normal
saint-exupéry comptabilise 330 vols de
jour pour 25 vols de nuit passagers et
marchandises confondues des vols de nuit
qui pose problème aux riverains
et même si leurs soucis ne date pas
d'aujourd'hui le confinement a servi à
tirer des conclusions claires pour
l'association contre l'extension et les
nuisances sonores de l'aéroport
lyon-saint-exupéry
le confinement a permis de se rendre
compte du bien fait d'avoir des nuits
calmes et donc
nous avons profité de
cette perception pour pouvoir relancer
une idée qui nous est chère depuis fort
longtemps et qui est d'une part la
diminution si des vols de nuit voire
leur arrêt complet alors notre souhait
évidemment ce serait d'avoir une trêve
nocturne au minimum entre minuit et 5h
du matin de façon à permettre d'avoir
une quantité de sommeil qui ne soit pas
hachée par les différents vols pour
l'ensemble des riverains
et ce n'est pas la seule association qui
monte au créneau coriace le comité des
riverains de l'aéroport saint-exupéry
créée celle ci il ya presque un demi
siècle va encore plus loin
elle demande une table ronde avec les
pouvoirs publics nationaux et locaux
pour nous quelque part c'est une rupture
de l'égalité du droit du citoyen parce
que il n'y a pas de raison que dans un
aéroport on décide que les avions de
telles catégories en termes de bruit ne
puisse pas volé parce que ça le dérange
les gens et puis qu'ailleurs ça n'existe
pas le modèle économique aujourd'hui il
est plus basé sur le profit immédiat
le problème c'est que on a complètement
occulté le modèle économique sociale
environnementale et durable et que on
peut pas indéfiniment continuer dans ce
sens là
pour l'instant aucune des deux
associations a reçu de suite favorable à
ces demandes
mais l'aéroport a lancé une étude
toujours en cours sur l'impact
économique d'un éventuel arrêt ou d'une
réduction des vols de nuit